welcome to this video got white again
against immortal from Argentina right
yeah and a Dutch defense yeah white as
many ways to combat the Dutch c5
interesting yeah well Bishop g5 is
mostly designed to get some simple piece
play going in term two to set up a
healthy structure I think c5 and Queen B
sixes quite an ambitious way to play
against that frankly speaking it looks
am simply bad to me why would you move
the Queen so early I mean it doesn't it
doesn't really make much sense okay
after this and I think black just needs
to retreat or I'm not quite sure what is
ideas or queen 85 yeah maybe queen 85 I
will I will go just see three after
Queen 85 and um very I'm just intending
to take on c5 not sure if 95 really was
such a great idea but it's also not
obvious what he what he should do
maybe Bishop c4 even and then send then
be four next move this protects the
night so that after before takes on
before the night is not hang okay so it
takes right yo yeah well the Dutch
defense um is an opening that really
requires some let's say unprejudiced
play I mean this looks like a very weird
chest I mean you develop don't develop
you play B 5 + f5 and everything at once
I I really don't know what's the point
behind all this okay so um maybe just
drop back TM still has some issues with
this development I also just want to
pawn okay if I go to yeah I can go to 12
to h4 cannot play g5 at least them Queen
h5 looks like a disaster okay yeah well
I takes be I can just take to take back
with the pawn and I didn't calculate g5
now but I cannot believe in this move
after something like 95 from
this must be too much okay so castling
now maybe castling just oops oops mouse
lip I wanted to Castle King f1 is awful
of course Oh help yeah this is the only
way out to to to keep a playable
position here for black mouse lip mhm oh
well hmm ok so let's just drop this
background threatening night c7 and on
f4 I'm 95 is the IDM that's not even
doing that ok I need to get this is this
piece on g3 interplay of course king f1
and I mean without King this King move
the game would be probably over already
with moves like rookie one and so on I
mean this still devil looks a disastrous
for black even with with rock f1
God don't really see move not sure what
what you should play threatening night
c7 simple simple move and also of course
I'm threatening Knight f6 Queen h5
cannot castle maybe g6 but it's really
gnarly move yeah well this is not c7
okay but maybe there's something better
even okay that's so let's do this Wow to
use em oh come on d5 d6 isn't as strong
I'm not sure that I want to take the
rook this simply looks like it it opens
up the position on d6 now I rd6 it's
also also good maybe I can get the rook
into play in this fashion queen at five
I want to go Quinn f5 ok then it's got
Bishop of it is not really a thread
right that'd be five
so um yeah maybe just get the King here
need need Botox of course what about
Roxy six come on slugs and this should
really a mop it up against the king ya
know Nick sarouk yeah this what this got
somewhat hairy with with this King f1
King have one more slip from from a
really nice um a really nice position
here of course just castles and and its
really really nice i'm talking everyone
had got somewhat strange but the whole
opening was really weird i think from
from blacks perspective why would you
play c5 and Queen B 6 that's at least
risky I mean under mat god god awful
pretty quickly here the computer
actually just wants to go ki Queen to d2
and this is strong I didn't consider it
Queen d2 Ted exchange and then black
needs to play King to d8 this really am
is very very nicely coordinate position
for white and black needs to play with
liking the a
but this is not bad i mean can play that
but certainly the other thing was was
somewhat stronger yeah thanks for
watching